peut-être plus incisive et est-ce que
vous estimez avoir réussi ce débat
vous êtes merveilleux les journalistes
vraiment quand je suis incisif je le
suis trop quand je le suis moi je ne
suis pas assez bon on a eu 2h30 de débat
qui ont été respectueux ce qui est
important c'est les projets le font et
on a pu je crois avec beaucoup de
respect l'un pour l'autre mais en étant
clair sur le fait que nous combattons
nos idées l'un contre l'autre j'ai eu
face à moi un Emmanuel Macron égale à
lui-même
très méprisant très arrogant
y compris dans sa posture ça n'a étonné
je crois aucun Français qui eux-mêmes
subissent cet arrogance et ce mépris
j'ai été très surpris par l'attitude
d'Emmanuel Macron une attitude que j'ai
trouvé arrogante méprisante avachi au
fond de son fauteuil et qui je crois sur
le poids des images qui laissent
derrière lui symbolise assez bien la
manière qu'il a eu considérer le débat
et la démocratie pendant cinq ans dans
notre pays a commencé parce qu'il a été
appelé la mou d'Emmanuel Macron lors de
la première prise de parole de Marine Le
Pen l'image a rapidement été détournée
parfois perçue comme une forme
d'arrogance ou de condescendance du
président candidat une posture qui
pourrait même rappeler pour certains
celle d'un psy puis on a vu un président
de la République alors excusez-moi mais
avachi d'une posture
désinvolte extrêmement arrogant
physiquement physiquement dès le début
qui se tenait très mal bon alors il
n'avait pas tout à fait tort Macron
était bien avancé sur sa table pendant
une bonne partie du débat le reste du
temps il a passé affalé au fond de sa
chaise à la fraîche
on attaque et qu'on critique sur la
forme c'est qu'on a à priori assez peu
d'arguments à donner sur le fond c'est
ça que je retiens je trouve assez peu de
choses à dire sur le fond de ce qu'a dit
le président de la République oui c'est
un procès qu'on lui fait tout le temps
le procès de l'arrogance moi j'ai pas vu
de l'arrogance
j'ai vu de la détermination la
conviction de la volonté de défense son
projet il a bien raison on l'attaque il
se défend et puis résultats qui ont été
quand même je dirais
très négative on va en reparler le pré
russe etc moi je peux vous en parler
c'est une longue tradition du Front
national que d'aller emprunter à
l'étranger parce qu'il est le peuple en
France reconnaissant le
contestez écoutez d'abord quand même le
Pen a fait cette empreinte monsieur
Macron n'était pas en responsabilité
politique deuxièmement
malgré une soixantaine de dossiers qu'on
a déposés auprès des banques françaises
alors qu'on présentait toutes les
garanties dans mes messieurs Macron il
est mal venu si vous voulez quand elle
parle à son banquier marine le penier
Emmanuel Macron a une dépendance
financière extrêmement forte et qui
explique sans doute ces positions
politiques de toute façon il n'y a pas
d'autres explication objectivement en
tout cas Emmanuel Macron sait se tenir
quand il le faut quand l'adversaire est
d'un tout autre calibre il peut même
être un poids trop figé sur sa chaise
cette fois c'était Poutine qui était en
avant un peu avachi peut-être un signe
de mépris à voilà ma position c'est la
même une séquence qui a fait couler de
l'encre et les twittos sont été nombreux
à modifier le message de la candidate du
rassemblement national à noter aussi la
réaction sur les réseaux sociaux de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le troisième homme du
premier tour qui a écrit ceci quel
gâchis le pays méritait mieux vivement
le troisième tour dit-il et comme par
magie un nom c'est invité en pleine
affrontement sur le chômage on est
compte pas dans les chiffres du chômage
ne faites pas ils se sont contents c'est
pas Gérard Magix ce soir Madame Le Pen
ce que vous regardiez le débat bien sûr
j'attendais qu'on parle de moi
j'ai cru rêvé je j'ai du mal comprendre
à Sarlat je suis un peu fatigué
non non pas sûr que c'est quelques trois
heures d'échange et fait bouger les
lignes le dernier sondage la sortie
juste après le débat à corde un point de
plus Emmanuel Macron un point de moins à
Marine Le Pen cela dit vous savez les
hommes politiques sont un peu
désillusionnistes il faut apparaître